everybody needs to learn to code coding
is the new literacy if you can't code
you'll soon become obsolete plus coding
is easy so you really have no excuse
these are all statements that are not
true but i've been told that fear-based
sales tactics will scare you into
subscribing to my youtube channel in
today's video i'm going to share a
variety of practical techniques that
have helped me learn to code because
learning in and of itself is a skill and
if you want to be a software engineer
you'll need to learn new things all the
time many moons ago i didn't know how to
code i wanted to learn because i hated
my low paying miserable job and wanted
to build some kind of app on the
internet that would allow me to break
out and start my own business i figured
i wasn't smart enough to code but you
only live once so i bought a giant book
about php and mysql and sure enough i
wasn't smart enough to code and those
toilets weren't going to clean
themselves i went back to my crappy job
and forgot about it luckily a little
while later my family needed a website
so i figured i was at least smart enough
to learn html and somehow a few months
later i figured out how to ship my first
website the important thing to recognize
when learning to code is that hard work
is more valuable than talent talon is
great if you have it and there are 10x
developers out there where things just
click on a much higher level but
programming is a skill very similar to
playing a musical instrument or juggling
for most people you totally suck at
first then you feel like a genius when
you code your first program then you
realize you totally suck again and this
pattern goes on and on forever in an
infinite loop learning is supposed to be
painful in fact i believe that you need
pain to grow when learning a guitar you
need to put your fingertips through a
lot of pain before you build calluses in
programming you'll have to bang your
head against the keyboard a bunch of
times until you figure out how to make
these error messages go away so if you
don't have talent be prepared to embrace
the hard work now as you learn you might
be wondering which programming language
should i start with the truth is that it
doesn't matter as long as you get really
good at one of them the thing about
programming is that there's so much to
learn you are never going to retain at
all i used to be a really good ruby
programmer but at this point i've
forgotten almost everything about it and
that's no big deal because memorizing
syntax doesn't really matter the thing
you really want to learn and retain are
programming patterns essentially
everything you do in programming is
problem solving the idea is to create a
repertoire of tools in your brain that
you can then use to solve virtually any
problem in any language for example if
you need to loop over something but
you've never used pearl before you still
understand the trade-offs between a for
loop while loop and recursion this is
the exact reason that when you go to a
technical interview they usually don't
care which language you use they just
want to see that you know how to solve
problems and in some cases they may only
have you write pseudocode on a
whiteboard to analyze your
problem-solving skills so in learning i
would recommend trying out a few
different languages and learn the one
that feels most natural to you for most
people i think python is ideal because
it has a minimal syntax is extremely
popular and is also just a very useful
language to know in general but
javascript go kotlin and swift are also
good languages to start with but again
it's about becoming a problem solver not
about memorizing syntax and that begs
the question how do i become a good
problem solver the answer is go solve a
bunch of problems turn off youtube and
go write some code will you ever learn
to play guitar by watching other people
on youtube play guitar the answer is no
you also need to be playing the guitar
along with them books and tutorials are
great sign up for fireship pro but
they're utterly useless if you're not
coding along with them in my tutorials i
try to set you up with something cool to
build so you can go have fun and fail on
your own you can build things based on
tutorials you can try to build your own
stuff you can do coding challenges
participate in hackathons and all kinds
of other stuff if you're serious you
should be coding at least a couple hours
every day there's a reason they require
pilots to have a certain number of
flying hours experience matters more
than anything else and luckily for you
to get time in the saddle all you have
to do is sit on your ass in front of
your computer screen and hit the
keyboard until something cool happens
speaking of which sitting on your ass in
front of a computer screen is not
natural or healthy and that means you
need to work extra hard in this line of
work to protect your health both
mentally and physically that's why i
prefer to eat at arby's the most trusted
name and nutrition i also get plenty of
sunshine and exercise to offset the time
i spend banging my head against the
keyboard in my mom's dark windowless
basement if your health is not optimal
you won't learn as efficiently and
there's no activity in the world that's
worth sacrificing your health over now
let's switch gears and talk about a
physicist named richard feynman he's a
nobel prize winner known for many things
one of which is his learning technique
it goes like this choose a concept you
want to learn about explain it to a 12
year old reflect refine simplify then
organize and review in other words you
learn most efficiently when you try to
teach the very thing you're learning i
can tell you right now that i've learned
way more about programming from running
this youtube channel than i ever did
working all by myself now that doesn't
mean that everybody needs to go and
start a youtube channel all you have to
do is pretend to teach something but if
you can create valuable content out of
it like a video or blog post that's even
better or if you already have a job
you'll find that you learn a lot just by
mentoring other people or if you don't
have a job you can join programming
slack or discord channels and help
people out there or answer questions on
stack overflow helping others feels good
and it forces you to be extremely
precise about what you actually know
here's how it might look for a
programmer choose a topic like i want to
program a video game do some research
and experimenting and write a summary
explaining the technology to a 12 year
old then go and build something and get
to a full working demo as quickly as
possible it doesn't need to be perfect
because in the final step you'll go back
and refactor and simplify and find ways
to improve your process and get feedback
from someone more experienced than you
if possible so approach it like a
teacher even though you have no idea
what you're currently teaching now i
said something very subtle but very
important and that is to build a full
working demo as quickly as possible
learning is supposed to be painful but
there also needs to be some kind of
reward for that pain and the more
quickly you can get to those rewards the
better because what you want is a
positive feedback loop that basically
makes you addicted to coding there are
ways we can hack the most primitive
parts of our brain what i do almost
every day before i go to bed is write
down a few small goals that i want to
achieve the next day the important thing
is that the goals are achievable because
then writing a check mark next to that
goal feels good when good things happen
your brain releases dopamine and you
want to try to find activities that
after hard work give you that dopamine
hit because otherwise you'll have a
negative feedback loop in which case
you're going to absolutely hate coding
in no time that'd be like learning how
to press the strings on a guitar without
ever knowing how to play an actual song
the idea is to work hard and be rewarded
but you don't want to work too hard it's
extremely important especially for
programming to pace yourself and take
regular breaks for most people that
likely means one or two hours of
programming followed by a nice long
break i remember in my early days being
absolutely determined to not let the
error messages win i'd go late into the
night stack overflowing every possible
combination of questions only to give up
and get a good night's sleep and then
come back and immediately solve the
problem in the morning and this isn't
unique to me it happens to everybody
because mental spacing is actually a
very important thing you can be mentally
exhausted while at the same time your
ego is saying you got this bro don't be
a loser but the reality is that the most
efficient thing to do is go outside get
some sunshine jump in a cold body of
water and get some sleep when you wake
up you'll be ready to crush it once
again now that you know how to learn to
code all you have to do is go to google
type in what you want to learn and let
it be your guide because that's
basically all you ever do as a software
engineer i'm going to go ahead and wrap
things up there make sure to hit the
subscribe button to get the next video
in this installment about mastering the
technical interview thanks for watching
and i will see you in the next one